welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast in this
week's episode Greg and I discuss a new
discovery about lactate we're not really
sure what it means but it definitely
seems like it could be important
after that Greg shares some very
impressive feats of strength and then I
share a research roundup segment where I
talk about protein intake sodium
bicarbonate supplementation dietary
fiber and more after that Greg gives an
overview of the research pertaining to
phototherapy
also known as laser therapy and then he
shares some tips for baking really good
bread finally Greg and I interview pro
strongman james deffenbaugh now James is
a very very accomplished strong man who
tells us all about the sport but he also
talked to us about tips for getting
started if you're interested in
strongman but you've never given it a
shot one quick correction before this
episode begins last week I mentioned
that we had extracted and categorized
clips from all of our previous Q&A
episodes and put them up on stronger by
science calm
turns out we extracted clips from all of
our previous episodes not just the Q & A
s to check out this new resource head
over to stronger by science comm / Q a
as always thanks for listening and enjoy
the show
welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host Eric Trexler and today I'm joined
by a special temporary guest host Greg
knuckles thanks for having me on thank
you for joining me now before we get
into our prepared segments for today you
posted something to social media this
week that is absolutely fascinating now
I don't think it warrants a research
review segment because I don't
understand it but it's interesting
enough to at least acknowledge it as
kind of a news article so nature the
prominent scientific journal they had a
little like press release article about
a paper that they recently published so
the the title of the kind of press
release more lay press type article was
histone lacked elation links metabolism
and gene regulation so for anyone
listening who doesn't have at least some
level of background in genetics the
reason this is important is when your
DNA is in the cell a lot of it is
wrapped around these things called
histones they help organize your DNA so
it's not just flopping around all over
the place essentially and the areas of
your DNA that are wrapped tightly around
histones are then inaccessible to be
read you know so the proteins that go in
and read the DNA to make the RNA strands
to make the proteins to have a really
tough time getting to these segments of
DNA that are wrapped around histones and
so in the field of epigenetics histone
modifications are important because
adding certain things to histones either
makes the DNA wrapped around those
histones more or less accessible which
then affects gene expression which then
affects what proteins are made which
then affects function so just to make
sure we're all on the same page here
when we're talking about Lac deletion of
histones that's a histone modification
which ultimately can affect gene
expression so that's that's what we're
talking about
just to make sure everyone's on the same
page here now we already knew about a
whole bunch of different types of
modifications that histone proteins can
be subject to so we know about histone
phosphorylation methylation acetylation
citrulline ation all sorts of different
post translational modifications however
this new study that came along added
another one to the mix that had not
previously been characterized so this is
a lactate related post translational
histone modification and so this is a
pretty big deal you know a lot of the
people who are probably reading this and
intend to do something with it
are in the field of oncology but for us
when we think lactate we're not thinking
cancerous tumor metabolism we're
thinking hey I have a close personal
relationship with lactate I generate a
whole bunch of that stuff when I
exercise so I think a lot of people in
the fitness and exercise related area
probably saw this headline and thought
what does that mean for me and frankly I
don't know what do you think reg I also
don't know right so that's why we're not
doing a research review segment on it is
because it's one of those things that
you see the headline and you realize hey
this could potentially be awfully
meaningful but in the meantime we don't
know what it might mean it's possible
that it might not be all that relevant
whatsoever but it certainly seems to be
fairly important so a somewhat related
thing sup versity calm it's run by Adel
Musa so on the SUP versity back in 2015
that he did a little write-up about a
study that was pretty fascinating I
don't to go too far into the details
because we're getting really really
speculative when it comes to this
particular topic but in any case he
reviewed a study that there was a cell
culture component and there was a rodent
component and to wrap both of these
studies into one singular kind of
summary statement what they did was they
either exposed these the cell
cultures or gave the rodents a lactate
treatment with or without caffeine and
what they found was there were
indicators that certain anabolic
pathways were upregulated either within
those cultured cells or in the rodents
themselves so an upregulation of some
anabolic pathways and they also saw
increases in muscle mass and my own
nuclei number which we discussed about
900 episodes ago I don't remember what
episode that was but we talked a lot
about my own nuclei and satellite cells
so it was a mechanistic paper saying
interesting it looks like lactate with
or without caffeine might be doing
something that goes very far beyond
metabolism and it's more related to cell
signaling so whether or not that's
related at all to these histone
modifications I have absolutely no idea
but science is really cool there's some
really smart people who over the next
five or ten years are gonna spend a lot
of time trying to get to the bottom of
this this new type of lactate related
histone modification and what that might
mean for physiology yeah I agree I think
I think just in general a lot of I think
a lot of people have written lactate off
too probably too great of a degree like
I think lactate kind of had a pendulum
we're way back in the day everyone
thought that you know it was what caused
the burn and then post exercise soreness
and it was just this bad thing and then
I think like people started seeing it as
more benign and I think more recently
people used to think that it might or at
least like some type of metabolic stress
or like something produced during
metabolically stressful contractions
might improve muscle hypertrophy and
within the last like a year or two it
seems like the tide has shifted and
people are moving towards like solely
tension based models and I kind of feel
like met up
like stress in general and lactates
specifically have probably been written
off a little bit too soon
part of the reason why is you know we're
talking about you know the effects of
lactate on epigenetics now but lactate
has lactate affects a lot of signaling
pathways that haven't been like fully
investigated to this point and I think
the research that people point to to
kind of suggest that metabolic stress in
general and lactate specifically may not
influence hypertrophy isn't necessarily
the best designed research because like
lactate isn't the thing being randomized
so for example you might have two
different training programs one of which
causes greater lactate accumulation and
you see similar hypertrophy after those
two training programs so you say oh we
didn't see more hypertrophy with greater
lactate accumulation therefore lactates
not doing anything interesting I don't
think you can necessarily draw that
conclusion because the thing that
differed was you know the entire
training program the intensity you were
training at how many reps you were doing
and one of the outcomes there is how
much lactate is produced but it's not
like the two programs were identical
except for the amount of lactate so
anyway it's not that's not a great
experimental model to isolate that
single variable and I just generally
think lactate is more interesting than I
think a lot of people give it credit for
see I I very much agree with Erick here
we can't necessarily do anything with
this new finding right now but I
definitely I definitely think it's an
area of research to kind of keep your
eye on moving forward alright so moving
on to things that are a little bit more
in our wheelhouse let's talk about some
feats of strength yeah so to start with
gonna go with one that I hope everyone's
seen already if you haven't take a
second google it right now Julius Maddox
who I feel like has been in at least
half of our strength
feats of strength segments up to this
point in the show recently hit what
might be the craziest set of benchpress
I've ever seen
he benched 700 for a triple with appalls
and all of the reps looked quite clean
so I mean he currently has the record at
somewhere around 740 doing 700 for a
triple I definitely think we're gonna
see 750 plus the next time he competes
I've heard he's been talking about
benching 800 plus and I mean the way his
train is going and the rate at which his
strength is improving that seems
incredibly plausible to me which is
crazy to even think about so anyway
Julius Maddux is a beast that's number
one
second feet of strength is Joseph
Amendola USA PL lifter competes in the
231 weight class or 105 kilo class
recently benched 580 pounds or 263 kilos
it wasn't at a meet with international
ref so it's not an official IPF world
record but it is an unofficial world
record beating the second place by ten
and a half kilos or 23 pounds which is a
pretty huge increase for a bench record
I'm pretty sure he did it in a full meet
as well which is super impressive looked
him up on open powerlifting and open
powerlifting is saying he's only 25
years old which you know suggests to me
that he very well may become only the
second ever
drug-free venture to go 600 plus Rock
Lewis did that back in 2006 in a
federation with probably not quite as
high of testing standards as USA PL or i
PF affiliates for what it's worth also
for what it's worth I was about 30 feet
away from ROC Lewis when he hit that 600
bench it was awesome
one of
probably the most impressive things I
ever saw really early in my strength
career and it looks like someone is
getting back to those numbers now under
probably more rigorously tested
conditions
so anyway 580 at 231 Joseph Amendola
super super awesome moving on so I may
mispronounce this name but max chef are
or Scheffer seventeen-year-old kid
competing in the 308 weight class or 140
kilo class dead lifted 722 pounds which
is ridiculous so previously the heaviest
deadlift for anyone 17 or under was six
ninety-nine point eight which is
something that makes more sense in kilos
but anyway he beat that by 10 kilos or
22 pounds heaviest deadlift ever
performed by someone that age so that's
ridiculous they didn't make 17 year-olds
like that back in my day two more really
quick
Yuri Belkin had a ho-hum performance by
his standards at big dogs recently he
only went 4 for 9 and still broke his
own world record in the 110 kilo class
or 242 class he totaled a thousand and
seventy kilos which is two thousand
three hundred and fifty nine pounds the
news I heard out of that meat is that he
injured himself on his first attempt
squat because his rack height was too
high so he just like strained something
trying to get the bar unwrapped and
trying to get set up for his first
attempt squat so he basically did an
entire meet injured only went 4 for 9
still broke his own world record so
that's wild just a day in the life of
Yuri Belkin I guess and then finally
probably the most controversial
inclusion on this list but still
impressive in its own right
is Dave HOF broke the 3100 pound barrier
and 1400 kilo barrier and the same meet
recently in multiplied untested
powerlifting the reason I say this might
be controversial is really since the WPO
collapsed initially I think it's fair to
say that the judging standard in
multiply powerlifting has been pretty
dissimilar to every other branch of
powerlifting so do with that what you
will I used to get upset about it as did
like everyone back in 2011-2012 the way
I see it these days is you know the
folks who compete and multiply know what
the rules are there know how the judging
is that's how they compete as long as
it's called the same for everyone I
don't care if you know the way lifts are
called is different for multi ply versus
raw
I don't compete multi ply I don't have a
horse in the race you know as long as
he's getting the same calls everyone
else does it's fine that's a ridiculous
barrier to break I mean 30 100 pounds
across three lifts that was a 1200 plus
squat after squatting 1200 plus benching
a thousand plus and multiply and then I
think rounding out the day with an 875
deadlift which is I mean equipment
doesn't help deadlift nearly as much as
squatting bench so I mean that's super
impressive for anyone so anyway if you
hate multiply lifting you know don't
worry about it if you love multiply
lifting you're probably super stoked
about this barrier falling I mean as
someone who came up in the sport when
multiply was really the biggest game in
town I still think it's cool I still
have a bit of a soft spot in my heart
for it and I mean HOF is really in a
league of his own right now so props to
him it's nice to hear how age has
brought you some
much wisdom and calm calmness when it
comes to powerlifting judging so Julius
Maddux bench 700 for three and I saw the
video it didn't look like a particularly
difficult three which is insane
yeah I mean he he just broke 700 not
that long ago I could I could have my
timeline wrong but I want to say he got
to either like high sixes or low 7s kind
of on his own and then hit up Josh
Bryant who is a legendary powerlifting
coach and specifically has coached a lot
of very successful bench pressors and
that has just been a really good
relationship so so I think that
partially explains the you know massive
progress we've seen from him recently
but like Jesus Christ dude the 700 or
the 750 barrier hasn't fallen yet and it
looks it's already looking entirely
plausible that 800 is gonna happen when
you know it wasn't that long ago that
the list of people who had benched 700
was to people like when I got into the
sport
Scott Mendelssohn had recently become
the second person ever to bench 700 and
now someone is like legitimately
knocking on the door of the high sevens
like it's crazy absolutely crazy alright
so next segment we've got here is a
research roundup so I took a look at
some of the studies the last couple
months saw some interesting ones that
caught my eye there's no particular
theme with this research roundup it's
just kind of a mixed bag of things that
caught my eye and caught my attention it
might be somewhat useful so the first
one there is a study that came out the
effects of a novel by carbonate loading
protocol on serum bicarbonate
concentration a randomized controlled
trial basically when you when talk about
sodium bicarbonate supplementation there
are some studies showing some prompt
promising results but the one thing the
one caveat that you always have to
consider with sodium bicarbonate
is a pretty realistic likelihood of
gastrointestinal symptoms there's a lot
of people who when they take an Ergo
genic dose of sodium bicarbonate it just
completely disagrees with their stomach
and the results are not not good
definitely not pleasant so that it's
always been one of those things where
theoretically for a lot of athletes and
lifters there are circumstances where
sodium bicarbonate supplementation would
make sense but a lot of people decide
not to because why risk it when it comes
to the high likelihood of GI symptoms
now what this study was doing was
looking at whether or not we could tweak
the dosing protocol to get the same
levels of blood bicarbonate
but while avoiding those unfavorable GI
symptoms so what they did was they had a
placebo group that got no no sodium
bicarbonate whatsoever they got that
they had a group that had a pretty
typical sodium bicarbonate acute dose it
was 300 milligrams per kilogram taking a
single dose one and a half hours before
the blood measurement the other group
they kind of did an incremental dosing
strategy so 19 and a half hours before
the blood test they gave them 110
milligrams per kilogram 11 and a half
hours before the test they had 130
milligrams per kilogram four and a half
hours before they had 160 and then one
and a half hours before they had 200 so
obviously none of those doses were as
high as the comparison group which just
got a flat 300 dose one and a half hours
before that blood test now what they
found was in the more typical dosing
protocol two of the seven participants
reported severe GI symptoms which
basically mean they were like an eight
or a nine out of ten on some kind of
subjective severity scale but none of
the patients in this modified
incremental dosing protocol
none of those participants reported any
severe GI distress and they were able to
achieve I think
even slightly higher levels of blood
bicarbonate compared to the more typical
dosing strategy so you know that the
thing was with this study they didn't
look at performance outcomes or anything
like that it was just a straightforward
can we get this into the blood without
upsetting your stomach and the results
of this particular study would indicate
yes obviously it's a very small sample
it's the type of thing you'd like to
replicate crossover design is perfect
for this that's exactly what you want so
that you have people comparing symptoms
within the same person you know this one
hurt my stomach this one didn't that's
the perfect way to look at it the big
thing there with those types of studies
if you don't do a crossover design and
you just like take a group of people and
give them one treatment and take a
totally different group of people and
give them the other dosing protocol you
have to try to make sure or basically
hope that neither of what neither group
is going to be different than the other
in terms of how likely they are to be
really complaining about their GI
symptoms so crossover trial is perfect
for that so it is a small sample but but
that's one of the really nice features
of this particular design so hopefully
people will come by and try to replicate
that not only when it comes to the
symptoms but actually look at some
performance outcomes and one thing worth
noting as well just because everyone
when they see a small sample that's like
the first thing they jump on like small
sample you can't take anything reliable
away from this research one thing to
note is that small samples for crossover
research like with within group designs
are actually quite powerful so you don't
generally need that many subjects to
reliably detect whatever you're looking
for so like small samples for between
group research that can be super
problematic oftentimes research comes
out underpowered but for a crossover
design like the one they used in this
study a small sample is probably
perfectly appropriate and having a huge
number of people in this study if
anything would just be wasting resources
definitely
okay study number two I'm not gonna
spend a lot of time on it because it's
one of those things that is super
obvious but it's always a nice study to
have in your back pocket when somebody's
giving you a hard time and you're like
dude listen like this is just how it is
so we've talked I believe this one was
by Grant Tinsley and company we've
talked about some of grants research
before as it pertains to time restricted
feeding or intermittent fasting so this
one is called a purported detoxification
supplement does not improve body
composition waist circumference blood
blood markers or gastrointestinal
symptoms in healthy adult female so they
basically had a supplement it was a
thirteen hundred and fifty milligram
serving with a proprietary blend that
blend contained papaya leaf slippery elm
bark peppermint leaf and a whole bunch
of other Leafs and roots and seeds and
all that stuff now the good news is
their study found no harmful effects of
supplementation no you know nothing
changed whatsoever but at least nothing
got catastrophic ly bad so that's that's
a good thing but basically they took
this whole host of measurements the the
supplement was indeed safe it didn't
cause any horrible outcomes but it just
did absolutely nothing whatsoever so it
seems like certain times of the years
these teas detox supplements get really
big usually it's when people who are
typically you know not that into fitness
kind of general population folks start
dipping their toes into fitness and
thinking like okay new year let's try to
tighten things up and see what we can do
that's when I feel like you see a lot of
these supplements make a big push and
you start to hear a lot more people
talking about them on social media and
stuff so this is something that I think
a lot of people can improve on in the
fitness space is you know you're into
fitness if you're if you're listening to
this podcast you're pretty into it right
and there's going to be people in your
life either in person or on social media
that you are in contact with who at some
point aren't into fitness and they're
going to kind of dip their toes in and
try some things it's always good to set
a good example for those
and to make sure that you're not pushing
people away from from trying to get into
cool things so if you see somebody who's
like just kind of getting into fitness
and they're like oh I just got this cool
new detox supplement what you shouldn't
do is put them publicly on blast what
you shouldn't do is make them feel
really stupid for doing it just hop in
the comments you [ __ ] dumbass right I
can't believe you yeah you've been in
the gym for two months and you don't
know everything I know already how
[ __ ] dare you exactly and so like
it's we're recording this in November
come December in January there's gonna
be some new folks who aren't that into
fitness who don't listen to fitness
podcasts and read Fitness literature and
some of them are going to reach for some
of these detox supplements that'd be
cool
but you know this is nice evidence that
you can show them saying like hey this
is like very accessible very applied
research people have looked into these
kind of products they don't seem to do
much positive at all
but you know don't don't try to make
people feel really stupid because you it
just might work
and people are gonna be like hey I tried
to participate in Fitness I had a
horrible time and everybody was mean to
be and so now I'm just gonna not do it
anymore
same thing goes with your gym etiquette
you know when this time of year comes
around be nice to people be cool
but yeah so detox supplements I they're
just not doing much and I'm gonna leave
it at that on the topic of detox so one
of I think the best strategies you can
use if someone's like really into detox
stuff is just ask them like oh cool
it this is supposed to detox you what
specific toxins is it ridding you of and
you know don't ask that in like a super
judgmental way but oftentimes that's
enough to just get the person thinking
like oh I don't actually know
specifically what this is supposed to do
the person or website that sold it to me
seems to have left you know pretty big
gaps in my knowledge so I mean that that
can be an effective way especially if
you don't ask it in
like a gotcha type way which I think a
lot of people do ask that any very
gotcha type wave that's exactly what I
was gonna say it's like that question
can be so constructive and so
counterproductive at the same time
purely based on how you ask it yes but
in the realm of accessible supplements
that do actually have detox benefits so
the algae I don't know if it's
pronounced spirulina or spirulina but
it's actually been shown to pretty
reliably chelate heavy metals so
ironically it's not incredibly uncommon
for nutritional supplements to have
higher levels of heavy metals than would
be advisable just because like they're
produced in sketchy factories overseas
sometimes and so I mean like heavy metal
poisoning is not a super common thing in
developed economies but it is something
that can theoretically happen that is
something that can have a toxic effect
and spirulina has actually been shown to
deal with those specific toxins so
that's a thing
furthermore it has some other benefits
as well at least one study I think maybe
in soccer players showed that it could
increase lower body power by a little
bit and it also helps with rhinitis
symptoms or stuffy runny nose so you
know if if there is someone in your life
who is just really sold on the idea of
detoxing and like you know you can't get
them off of it they're just sold that
like I want to do a detox or I want to
take something to detox me is kind of
like a harm mitigation tactic you can
just point them in the direction of
spirulina it's probably going to have
neutral to positive effects for most
people
and it does actually you know it can't
actually detox specific things if
someone just happens to have high levels
of heavy metals in their body well Greg
I got bad news that proprietary blend I
don't think it had that in it
unbelievable unbelievable okay a couple
studies came out recently on protein
intake specifically looking at protein
intake intended to maximize the anabolic
response to resistance training so the
first one I want to look at is called
this is a long title protein intake to
maximize whole body anabolism during
post-exercise recovery and resistance
train men with high habitual intakes is
several fold greater than the current
recommended dietary allowance that's a
lot of words for a title Greg okay so
this was a pretty straightforward they
did some whole body resistance training
and basically they did several different
protein doses to try to figure out how
much is enough and what they what they
used for their analysis was something
called biphasic linear regression
basically what they were looking for is
is there a breakpoint right so you would
think as you increase that protein dose
you get better and better and better and
better results but at a certain point
that's likely to level off and
essentially become a flatline where it's
like okay you've maximal you maximized
it enough that it's fine and so what
they found with their analysis was the
breakpoint they found was right around
two grams per kilogram per day of
protein and there have been other
studies in the past at least at least
one or two other studies that have taken
a similar approach with the analysis
where they're like we're basically
looking for a breakpoint here where does
where do where do these benefits seem to
really level off and what's the the
point where we can say yeah at this
level you've probably done what you're
trying to do and I believe at least one
of those other papers identified a
breakpoint that was at a very similar
spot it was like one point eight or two
something around that
park so I think at least in the in with
using this kind of research paradigm of
kind of short-term studies looking at
these anabolic responses it seems like
there's growing evidence that is helping
us triangulate a general range of where
protein is likely to kind of max out
that benefit you know that's one way you
can view it I view this as just the
insidious lobbying of big protein trying
to pad their wallets over time because
as of just a handful of years ago they
were saying one point eight grams per
kilogram per day and now they're saying
two point oh that's ludicrous those are
incredibly different numbers there's no
way that you could explain that just by
different populations and different
studies making it into the sample it's
clear that you know in the past few
years big protein has obviously ramped
up its lobbying efforts to you know try
to make about ten percent more money off
of protein powder sales and I can't
believe you are blind enough to actually
fall for this trap that they're setting
so I know that you're not doing this on
purpose because we simply do not work
that hard but you're going to be shocked
to hear this next study the next study
is called should competitive
bodybuilders ingest more protein than
current evidence-based recommendations
now Greg you were upset about that
increase from 1.8 to 2.0 so we're
talking about a difference of point two
well in this paper this is a quote
verbatim in regard to maximizing muscle
hypertrophy
it would seem prudent for bodybuilders
to consume at least 2.2 grams per
kilogram
hmm so we've literally already gone
we've doubled up the increase that you
found to be so egregious and now we're
at 2.2 in this study at this point is
too obvious do they really think they
can get away with this no one's stopping
them so they're going to keep pushing
now discuss
they also said in the study there's some
evidence indicating that a higher
ingestion of protein up around 3 grams
per kilogram per day may have some
applications you and I have a love-hate
relationship with the gentleman named
dr. Eric Helms he published a review a
few years back saying that around 2.3 to
3.1 grams per kilogram per day of lean
mass so fat free mass not total body
mass might make sense particularly if
you're a bodybuilder in a deficit so if
you're in a caloric deficit and
retaining muscle is one of the most
important parts of your day and if
you're a prepping bodybuilder it is
there might be times when going above
that range of 1.8 to 2.2 grams per day
but there might be some reasons to do
that in in some of those unique
circumstances but for most people that
are not a prepping bodybuilder most of
the research is indicating if you're in
the high 1 to low 2 grams per kilogram
per day range you're probably at a level
that is essentially maximizing your
anabolic benefit from training now there
are some studies like whenever I think
of setting a protein intake I always
think you know what is the penalty of
going over and what's the penalty of
going under is it worse to over shoot
her to undershoot and when we're talking
about somebody whose strength or power
athlete or somebody with you know who
really prioritizes their physique
related goals the cons of going over
seem much more palatable than the cons
of under shooting your protein intake so
my general bias is to lean toward a
higher intake and going a little bit
over is of no meaningful consequence in
most cases going a little bit under is
just leaving gains on the table and who
wants to leave gains on the table we we
work way too hard to get them so uh you
know there are studies Jose Antonio's
done some of those studies with protein
intake where I think they've gone over
four grams per kilogram per day is that
right yeah I think I think four point
four is the high
- signed yeah I mean if you want to go
for 4.4 be my guest that sounds horrible
to me that does not sound like a fun way
to eat no I mean oh man
protein is so filling that that's got to
feel terrible absolutely terrible but
even in those really extreme cases like
you don't need to be up there but even
if you do go up there it doesn't seem to
be particularly devastating
I think settling in and that you know
1.6 1.8 2.2 somewhere in that range is
probably where most people are gonna
find themselves so that's one
perspective another perspective is I
recently saw a Netflix documentary that
suggested that Cal's in fact have more
muscle than humans and don't eat that
much protein I don't know just something
to stew on so or would you suggest that
body that the real question is not how
much protein per day should a
bodybuilder built body builder eat but
how many kilograms of grass should they
eat in a given day look I'm not making
claims I'm just asking questions and I
don't know why you seem so hesitant to
ask questions what's your point you
should be able to talk about this in the
free marketplace of ideas no you're
right so there's that's why people come
to this podcast it's fair and balanced
you're gonna get both sides of the story
and people are free to make make up
their mind look you you have science and
I have the rhetorical move of the cows
though and I honestly think that those
are equally compelling fair enough let's
switch gears to something a little bit
less controversial let's talk about
fiber so there's a study within the last
month or two called fiber intake
predicts weight loss and dietary
adherence in adults consuming calorie
restricted diets so this was they were
looking at the pounds lost study so it
was a randomized trial looking at some
different calorie restricted
diets intended to induce weight loss in
adults a pretty big study 345
participants they provided their dietary
records at baseline in six months and
the the weight lost the average weight
loss at that six-month time point for
the full sample was seven about 7.3
kilos um so that you know it's a nice
chunk of weight to lose over a six-month
period now they put together a big old
regression model to try to find all the
predictors that related to weight loss
in the sample and obviously fibre was
not the only one fibre was not you know
driving the entire weight loss effect
but they did find that of all the things
they put into this model which included
energy density fat age adherence their
weight when they started changes from
baseline and a bunch of different
dietary factors they did find that fiber
intake was the biggest independent
predictor of weight loss success they
also found that the fiber was strongly
associated with adherence to the
macronutrient prescriptions that they
were provided now I am NOT of the of the
opinion that fiber does anything
remarkably magical but I do think that
fiber is an absolutely key component of
a really solid weight loss diet and I've
mentioned this on on the show before
when I start a weight loss diet the
first thing I do is I ramp up my intake
of fibrous vegetables my cauliflower
intake broccoli spinach it just goes
through the roof I start eating more
berries but I mean solid fiber intake
from really fibrous fruits and
vegetables is in my opinion for most
people going to set them up you know
it's not doing anything magical in the
diet but I think it's a really nice
first step to set people up for success
in most free living conditions
you start getting somebody onto a diet
that has plenty of fruits and vegetables
plenty of fiber their fullness goes up
their satiety is taken care of generally
speaking it is a
a filling satiating and typically
nutrient-packed really really solid
weight loss diet and that's pretty much
consistent with what they found in this
particular study was that you know it's
not like there was some you know people
treat these diet studies when they look
at individual factors sometimes people
see it as like well calories can't
explain it but fiber did it again we
have no idea how in this case you know
it's really straightforward it it helps
you feel very full and satiated from
your diet and it helps you stay on track
with your adherence and generally
speaking it's just a really solid way to
diet when you're in the weight loss game
now there's another study related to
fiber that I'm not gonna get too far
into the details on because frankly I'm
not gonna pretend that I have a really
really thorough understanding of the gut
microbiome I think the internet is full
of people who do but I think the number
of people who are eager to profess
expertise about the gut microbiome is
way larger than the people who possess
expertise on the gut microbiome so I
think is it can I give a spoiler we're
gonna have we're gonna have Gabrielle
from daro on the on the podcast and
she's gonna tell us everything we want
to know about about the gut microbiome
but for now I can at least appreciate an
interesting finding so there was a it
was kind of like a little summary of a
study that got published it was called
the key to successful weight loss on a
high-fiber diet maybe in gut microbiome
Prevotella abundance so there is this
study where they they classified
people's gut microbiota into three
groups and they call them enterotypes
and even from just a cursory kind of a
little bit of background reading so they
grouped them into these three and Tarot
types and apparently there's some
controversy over how useful or I guess
robust those groupings are there's still
some controversy about whether or not
it's a good idea to be grouping in this
particular way so that's frankly looking
at the gut microbiome stuff I'm not sure
if there's anything out there that isn't
controversial among some experts in the
area it's it's like they're there
there's so much to be figured out and
then as people settle upon different
strategies for how they want to go about
researching these topics then you have
to form scientific consensus and people
start arguing about what the consensus
should be so this is a newly forming
area that you know there's all sorts of
controversy and disagreement and
argument which is why I just want to
very briefly kind of share what this
study found but it was a secondary
analysis from a six-week randomized
controlled trial and it was really
interesting because they they basically
you know they had high fiber and low
fiber diets within this dietary trial
and what they found was the subjects
that were grouped into one particular
and Tarot type lost way more weight on
the high fiber diet than when they were
on the more kind of low or normal fiber
diet however people of a different in
Tarot type within the study essentially
remained weight stable no matter which
one they were on so this high fiber diet
for one in Tarot type was really
effective compared to the alternative
diet but for the other in Tarot type
essentially they didn't really see big
improvements with either diet so the the
full in depth results of that trial are
much more nuanced there's a third group
in the mix that was like an even more
special type of an Tarot type so so you
can really get into the weeds on that
study but it was a just kind of an
interesting thing that jumped out to me
that you know as we continued to figure
out more about the gut microbiome
there's a lot of questions about what
are the practical implications of that
there are a lot of questions about which
direction causality is going with a lot
of these studies in this particular case
it would appear that there was a
measurable difference in terms of
response to a high-fiber diet based on
the individuals baseline and Tarot type
that they started the study with now you
can take that one further level in terms
of calm
location and say but what happens when
they actually stick on this diet long
term and potentially have a shift in
their inteiro type so I mean the gut
microbiome stuff is generally just an
absolute minefield of complications and
disagreements and there's a lot of
nuance involved but in any case it's
something to keep an eye on is not just
how high fiber diets affect the
microbiome but also how your kind of
baseline microbiome might affect your
response to a high-fiber diet now the
thing to keep in mind though I say this
whenever we talk about some of these
interesting findings looking at
particular nutrients we're not talking
about violations of you know calories
and calories out this is not some kind
of weird flaw in physics the numbers
always work but usually in these types
of studies especially with free living
individuals what we'll find is that you
know these different aspects of the diet
could affect energy uptake from the diet
it could affect energy expenditure
it could affect simply adherence to the
diet so there are a lot of different
factors that could be involved but in
any case fiber very very cool and
usually whenever someone says hey I'm
going to try to lose some weight one of
the first things that come to mind is
what's your fiber intake like are you
getting a bunch of fibrous vegetables if
not you probably ought to yeah I feel
like and I feel like much like lactate
people kind of sleep on the degree to
which gut microbiota can affect things
so you were talking about fiber man so
maybe like two or three years ago there
was a study published that really stuck
in my mind where essentially what they
did is they they had two groups of
people so the first group of people they
took stool samples to look at their gut
microbiome just see what they had down
there and then had them try a whole
bunch of different foods and analyzed
their glycemic response to it so
basically what was your blood sugar
response to various carbohydrate
containing foods and then they look to
see like based on your gut microbiome
and what foods you had like the the
largest or like most surprising glycemic
response to which of like the different
types of bacteria were predictive of
having like a larger smaller glycemic
response to particular types of foods
and then in their second group they
essentially like have validated what
they found in the first group so they
use the first group to kind of like
train and algorithm and then kind of
like a priori they got stool samples
from the second group and said okay
based on what we're seeing from your
microbiome from from what we saw in the
first group in this study we think these
foods are going to give you a small
glycemic response and these foods are
going to give you a much larger glycemic
response and it turned out they were
right and the algorithm worked really
really well so I mean that's just kind
of like how a validation study works 101
but the surprising thing about it was
just how variable the high and low
glycemic foods were a person to person
based on their different gut microbiomes
so the one that sticks out in my mind
from the press release for the study is
they mentioned that for a couple people
their highest glycemic response was two
tomatoes which is generally not thought
of as a super high glycemic food and
then for some of the people foods that
are typically thought of as being higher
glycemic had you know much much smaller
glycemic responses than would be
expected so yeah I think it's I feel
like how you led in with this was
correct Trek's which is that a lot of
people think they know a lot about the
gut microbiome and then you know they
follow that up with like huge sweeping
statements which just due to the
variability we see I feel like simply
cannot be true
but but I do think that I do think the
evidence suggests that differences in
gut microbiomes can play a pretty large
role in determining how people are going
to respond and going to feel after
different diets but there's still a ton
of details to work out but I think it
kind of makes me more more willing to
just like believe people's like
subjective statements about their diets
so you know if if we know that one thing
is typically good for most people and
someone says oh I tried that felt like
[ __ ] my energy was awful you know I I'm
going to be less likely to say oh like
you're full of [ __ ] and just didn't give
it a chance and more likely to be like
oh well you know that's not a typical
response but I buy it because people
just have weird and super variable
responses to nutrition definitely and
I'm stoked to talk to to Gabrielle I've
got a whole bunch of questions about the
gut microbiome so listeners stay tuned
to that or stay tuned for that should be
a good one now Greg we've been getting a
lot of a lot of feedback from listeners
I probably every couple every couple
weeks I get an email you guys never talk
about lasers so finally all those people
that have been emailing me everybody
chill Greg is gonna tell us about lasers
yes so like treck said this is easily
one of the most common requests we get
for the show so let's talk about lasers
so there is what is what is called photo
therapy which is exactly what it sounds
like it's using light to do something
therapeutic so typically it would either
be infrared light or near-infrared light
so basically long wavelength visible
light so things at the very far end of
the red spectrum so either infrared or
near-infrared and they can do
so those wavelengths of the
electromagnetic spectrum and do several
different things in the body but most
relevant for exercise is they interact
with the cytochrome complexes within the
mitochondria and also with the
hemoglobin and myoglobin which are light
sensitive to some degree and essentially
what it does with the mitochondria is
just kind of make it work more
efficiently to speed up ATP synthesis
and with the hemoglobin and myoglobin
what it does is it shifts their redock
their redox status to make them more
likely to offload oxygen which is what
you want during exercise you want within
the muscle tissue you want oxygen to be
offloaded more efficiently at a given
po2 level and so you know kind of the
things that you won't happening
metabolically within your muscle tissue
during exercise phototherapy
helps those things along and so i I was
aware of this concept but I was under
the impression that it was one of those
things that you know maybe there was
some cell research on maybe there were a
couple animal studies but you know maybe
at most a couple human studies but not
all that much out there like that was my
impression but that was because I hadn't
salt out the research in the area and so
I'm reviewing a paper for mass this
month about photo therapy and its
effects on exercise performance and so
you know that led me to fire up PubMed
and see what else is out there and I
actually came across some pretty recent
meta analyses looking at the effects of
photo therapy on both exercise
performance and recovery from exercise
so in 2016 there was a meta-analysis
from Namco and colleagues titled
low-level photo therapy to improve
exercise capacity and muscle performance
a systematic review and
and so basically they just you know
pulled out all of the studies that had
looked at the effects of pre exercise or
like between set photo therapy on
exercise performance not a huge body of
literature but way more than I thought
there was so there were 16 studies in
the area and so they looked at things
like the degree to which it improved the
number of reps people could do during
dynamic resistance training it did have
a significant effect on that improved
and I mean this number probably doesn't
mean anything due to heterogeneous
protocols but a mean increase of about
three and a half reps across you know
various training protocols during
isometric tests they looked at
improvements in time to exhaustion there
was a significant increase there as well
they looked at its effects on blood
lactate levels it decreased the lactate
response to exercise by a bit 0.3 4
millimoles per liter and most
surprisingly to me it also increased
peak torque by about 21 newton meters
and just based on the known mechanisms
on like mitochondrial efficiency you
would think you know maybe it can
improve endurance but I wouldn't
necessarily think it would improve peak
torque but it does also seemed to
improve peak torque which is quite
interesting and so those are the effects
on exercise performance a slightly older
meta-analysis published in the Journal
of athletic training by borsa and
colleagues titled does photo therapy
enhance skeletal muscle contractile
function and post-exercise recovery a
systematic review also looked at a lot
of those same studies looking at
performance very very similar
conclusions but it also looked at
studies investigating various markers of
exercise recovery so you know mostly
just like the standard markers a muscle
damage that one would typically look at
so things like creatine kinase and
whatnot but there have also been a
couple studies where basically the
design is
is you have two groups trained and one
of the groups gets photo therapy either
during exercise or post exercise the
other group gets a sham treatment and
then you look and see how exercise
performance looks without photo therapy
24 to 48 hours later so basically
looking at performance recovery and so
what they find in those studies is not
only does photo therapy improve acute
performance but it also allows people to
recover from that performance a little
bit faster both in terms of markers and
muscle damage and recovery of
performance within the next 24 to 48
hours so that's cool
it kind of seems like you know it like
everything in the kitchen sink like
basically everything one would want out
of some sort of intervention to improve
exercise improves both performance and
recovery so that that may put you know
that may stimulate your your spider
senses as it were because you know
things that especially things that
improve recovery and decrease some of
those markers of inflammation may kind
of be one of those things where it's
good in the short term but not
necessarily the long term so you know we
see that with antioxidant supplements
with insets with cold water immersion
some of those things can decrease
markers and muscle damage maybe improve
short-term muscular recovery after
training but can inhibit muscle growth
and possibly strength gains
longitudinally so you know the question
is is photo therapy going to do that as
well and in fact it actually seems to be
less like cold water immersion and
NSAIDs and more like creatine in that it
improves performance and also may
improve longitudinal training outcomes
as well so I think there's less research
on this but I did find a study also by
Baroni
at all title of the study is effects of
low-level laser therapy on muscle
adaptations to knee extensor eccentric
training and so basically they had three
groups trained for eight weeks well one
was a control group they didn't train
one group trained just you know carried
out a training protocol you got the
third group did the same training
protocol but also got photo therapy
laser therapy along with their training
and over those eight weeks the group
also getting laser therapy had a
significantly larger increase in muscle
thickness for the muscles being trained
fifteen point four percent versus nine
point four percent a larger increase in
isometric peak torque and a larger
increase in eccentric peak torque so
anyway this all seems super super cool
helps you perform better helps you
recover better and may help you get
larger gains as well so here's the catch
the catch is that I don't know how much
faith we can have in commercial products
purporting to deliver this to you so
once I found this research I was like
holy [ __ ] this all sounds awesome
what is it gonna cost me to pick up like
a really high quality unit and so
essentially this is one of those things
where there's consumer-grade stuff and
research grade stuff so I searched one
of the units that had been used in one
of these studies just to see oh
if this sets me back a couple hundred
bucks I might make the splurge just to
see if it does anything turned out it
was like twenty thousand bucks which to
me not worth it
then I looked on Amazon to see if you
know there was consumer-grade stuff with
good reviews and I did find stuff that
at least purports to put out the same
sorts of wavelengths used in the
research at similar wattage to what's
used in the research for like 100 150
bucks and so that makes me mad skeptical
if there's like a 100 fold difference in
price between the stuff they use in
research and the stuff that's you know
consumer available and so like there are
several devices on Amazon that have good
reviews but the thing that makes me
really skeptical about them is they tend
to market themselves for like recovery
from injury or alleviating pain because
that's one of the other like researched
applications of photo therapy and
especially pain is super susceptible to
the placebo effect
so like essentially the more objective
something is the less susceptible to the
placebo effect it is the more subjective
something is them more susceptible it is
and so pain is essentially like the
ultimate subjective outcome measure and
so a lot of these products on Amazon
have great reviews people are like oh I
use this like it's been helping my bum
knee that's been bothering me for twenty
years but like I can't know that that's
not the placebo effect so essentially at
this point I am kind of sold that
phototherapy seems to be pretty legit I
am definitely gonna want to see more
longitudinal studies before I'm super
confident that it does actually improve
longitudinal like strength and
hypertrophy outcomes but it does look
like there's a pretty decent body of
literature backing up its effects on
improving acute performance and recovery
at this point which is great in its own
right I'm just not sure how much we can
trust the unit's that are out there on
the market that are actually affordable
so that's as I see it the drawback but
you know it's one of those things that
if you're looking for if you're looking
for something that could potentially
give you an edge like if you're a super
competitive power lifter
a builder and you know you're already
spending like 200 bucks a month on
supplements anyways it may not be the
worst idea to you know make a splurge on
one of those consumer products on Amazon
like hundred hundred and fifty bucks
like that's kind of pricey but it's not
ridiculous it may do good stuff for you
or you know maybe the products on Amazon
or bogus but the technology itself does
seem quite legit and it's something I'm
pretty excited about you know when you
were talking about it I kept thinking
about how readily kind of I guess you
would call them alternative recovery
modalities are adopted at high level
sport so like you know you turned on the
the last cycle of Olympics and
everybody's just covered with dots right
like yeah if you weren't cupping you
weren't trying it was basically like and
you know they do all the features like
oh look at this cool thing all the
athletes are doing now I wonder if
they're already doing this and if not
this would be my front runner for the
thing that during the next Olympics they
do a little like two-minute special on
so I think the original research on
photo therapy is actually like kind of
old I'm not sure how old but I remember
so when I was when I was like a
sophomore in college or between
sophomore and junior year I interned at
mash elite performance and Travis was in
in the process of starting a second
facility at the time and the second
facility kind of partnered with a
physical therapy clinic and so the guy
that owned that physical therapy clinic
he was he was into you know doing the
stuff that was super well supported and
evidence-based but then also like I
think his clinic was was quite
successful and so he was also willing to
like make the splurge on the stuff that
was starting to have like you know
evidence developing but wasn't super
well supported yet and so I remember the
first time I went to that facility and
met him he just wanted to show off some
of his toys and he had just gotten a you
to do laser therapy and so that was oh
that was 2012 I guess so I mean it's
it's not something that's super new I
mean at least some people knew about it
at least seven years ago or so so I mean
I don't know maybe it's something that's
already used a lot in high performance
settings but yet I mean to this point
the research is super promising and if I
had 20,000 bucks to drop on a unit I
would be pretty confident that that
would have a meaningful effect I'm just
not sure if I trust the hundred dollar
units you know yeah I definitely get
that just one other thing I'll note
about the body of research that's out
there which makes me trust it a little
bit more than I might otherwise so one
good sign for a healthy body of
literature is that you don't just see
all of the research coming from one
research group that's that's always a
little bit sketchy and so at this point
there seems to be three active research
groups in this area you see a lot of
papers with Leal jr. as the lead author
fair amount of papers with borsa as the
lead author and a fair amount of papers
with Baroni as the lead author so and
and it doesn't seem like there's like
really much overlap with those research
groups they're doing similar stuff
getting similar results which does make
me have more faith in it than I even
would otherwise so anyway yeah I just
find it super interesting and I mean
it's lasers lasers are cool that's
awesome yeah so you're gonna have that
in the December issue of mass you've got
a new article on on this therapy and you
sir within mass the author is we we have
an internal peer review process that is
infinitely more rigorous than any other
peer review process that occurs so I'm
pretty I'm pretty excited to to see what
you put together there I'll do my best
okay so I mentioned we get a lot of fan
mail asking for laser content that was
actually not
but one thing that is true is we often
get people asking for some more cooking
related content so to play us out for
this episode I understand Greg you've
got a little is it a cooking tip or a
recipe a cooking tip cooking tip all
right Greg the floor is yours
okay so I have been getting really into
bread baking recently kind of my
introduction to cooking was almost
exclusively stovetop and then grilling I
think I've gotten pretty good at both of
those things something that always
intimidated me a lot was yeasted breads
so I don't have as much experience with
bread baking but that's something I have
been experimenting with a lot recently
and one of the things that I want to get
really really good at is making really
good sandwich bread the reason for that
is I eat a fair amount of sandwiches
sandwiches are a pretty quick thing that
one can grab if they're in a hurry and
I'm generally busy so that's good and
they can be quite macro friendly like
most lunch meat is pretty lean a lot of
protein and then additionally my wife
loves toast eats it with breakfast every
day one of her favorite foods and so
generally sandwich bread also makes good
toast bread so you know I've tried to
set off to get really really good at
making sandwich bread and one of the
issues I kept running into is I would
bake these loaves they would come out of
the oven they would be perfect they
would taste great they would be soft
fluffy slightly moist everything someone
wants in sandwich bread and then by the
time we were halfway through the loaf
two or three days later it was already
going a little stale like the flavor was
changing somewhat it didn't have the
nice spring anymore and I mean that's
that is one of the drawbacks of making
your own bread one of the reasons that
store-bought breads are
so popular and so good is they tend to
put a fair amount of preservatives in
them too
you know let you use them over the span
of two or three weeks while they still
you know feel fresh taste fresh ish
maintain the texture you bought them
with and unless you're just gonna go for
those preservatives it's it's hard to
get that with home baked bread so I
recently came across a technique that I
don't know maybe it's popular in baking
circles but I had never heard of it and
it purported to make loaves of soft
breads both softer right when they come
out of the oven and also to help them
stay soft and supple and fresh tasting
longer and I hope I don't butcher this
pronunciation too much but the name of
the technique is pong Xiang I think is
close enough ta in G Z H Ong it's a
Chinese technique and so essentially
what it is is you start with a water
roux so if you are familiar with French
cooking at all you know that a roux is
typically just flour and butter that you
cook out a little bit so a water roux is
instead of going with a fat source like
butter you go either with all water or
mostly water so you know it could be
something like milk which is about 90%
water give or take and so essentially
when flour is heated up to above a
hundred and forty degrees Fahrenheit
which is something in Celsius and a 50
degrees I'm going to guess 50 60
whatever but a hundred and forty degrees
Fahrenheit it will gel it'll like the
the structure of it will change it's
going to absorb a shit-ton of liquid
like the difference in the texture of
your flour and water / milk mixture
between like 120 degrees and 140 degrees
is night and day it essentially makes
this thick paste which just sucks up all
of the water
and that's your water room and so
essentially you you take that integrate
it into a just otherwise generally
straightforward sandwich bread recipe
and it comes out softer fluffier and
since we just finished our first
pungsong loaf I can verify we kept it
for about six days before we finished it
and it did stay much fresher and with a
much more pleasant texture the entire
time so this this does seem to be the
way to do sandwich bread if you like
baking your own sandwich bread which I
would recommend you do it's fun it's not
all that hard it's a pretty easy
introduction to yeast into baking if
that is something you're interested in
trying so generally I tend to follow a
process of when I first get into a new
technique I follow recipes and then once
I kind of understand the science behind
what I'm doing and understand kind of
what makes the recipe tick then I start
putting my own spin on it so I'm not to
that point yet I just followed the Tong
Zhong milk bread recipe from King Arthur
Flour so if you just google that the
recipe I use should pop up it was
absolutely incredible I would highly
recommend it
Oh so I mentioned science the the thing
that this technique is doing is like I
said when you heat the the flour and
milk or water mixture up to 140 degrees
it gels the flour absorbs shit-ton of
liquid and so then when you put that
into the bread as even like a relatively
small percentage of the dough you're
gonna have that gelled flour that's
holding onto a lot of water and it like
maintains that structure so it just
allows the loaf to one have more
moisture in it when it's done baking in
the first place which makes it a little
bit softer when it comes out of the oven
and it does a really really good job of
holding onto that water for days at a
time which largely
the problem of homemade bread going
stale faster so anyway that's my baking
tip google it
again it is ta ng z h ong super super
cool and yeah if you bake some bread
with this technique send me a picture on
instagram tag me in your story whatever
and have fun with it
and if you're interested in learning
more about the science behind it there
is a youtube series called what's eating
dan starring a guy named Dan Sousa that
is where I found out about this
technique originally it's like a five
minute video so you can just search that
on YouTube really good video good
introduction to the technique I think
that's about all I have to say about
that perfect so you know some of our
listeners are a lot like you Greg they
like to put some time and effort into
their cooking they enjoy that a lot of a
lot of listeners are all out like me we
prefer a slightly more parsimonious
approach so just so we don't leave them
hanging an alternative thing you could
do I moved into a different apartment I
think about three or four months ago and
when I moved in I didn't have any food
right so I got some ultra processed
white Wonder bread and I'm still going
with that same loaf it's been keeping
very well still very fresh whatever
preservatives they're putting in there
is working no reduction in quality so I
don't know if you're getting your bread
the last four months but mine is doing
just fine
generally a loaf or breaths not gonna
make it for months
I'm doing fine believe it okay that
wasn't true don't eat gross bread that's
gonna make you ill alright so we've got
an awesome interview for this week's
episode we sat down and had a chat with
James deffenbaugh now James is a pro
strong man he also is the owner of a gym
in Raleigh called spider strength where
Greg actually trains if you've watched
any of Greg's recent training videos so
we talked to James and James
like I said he's a pro really really
high-level talented strong man so what
was cool about the interview was we
talked about some of the high level
strongman stuff but we also talked about
how a total beginner would even start
getting into strongman so I would
imagine a lot of our audience has
minimal exposure to strongman maybe
hasn't tried it themselves but is
interested in it but just doesn't know
where to start so it was a really nice
interview we kind of talked about both
ends of that strongman spectrum whether
you're interested into the really high
level competitors or you know you're
interested in just giving it a shot
yourself so James is a super cool guy
really fun to talk to got a really
informative interview after the music as
always thank you so much for listening
and we'll see you in a week
[Music]
[Music]
all right so joining us today is James
defin ball
James how are you doing doing well
thanks for having me thank you for for
gracing our humble podcast with your
presence yeah I would also like to
submit this interview as an interview
for the temporary guest host position I
don't have a strong science background
but I have a strong stronger background
which I think would be a good fit to the
show so we're open to just about any
alternative so your background is
totally sufficient and I've got a pretty
long backlog of submissions but I will
put you to the top all right I
appreciate it
so Trek's is kind of angling for Dwayne
the rock Johnson to be the the permanent
co-host he hasn't returned to many of
our emails yet but but Trek's thinks
that lead is starting to heat up but but
if that falls through I'm sure he'll
he'll contact you so the problem is
Dwayne is surrounded by a lot of bad
folks and his management his agents are
they don't know what they're doing I
missed him the first time because he was
on vacation so it's things are moving
along him trust me okay
anyway so so so James just so just so
the listeners know who they're listening
to right now to tell us a little bit
about your background you know just what
what do you do on a day to day basis and
how you got into the sport of strongman
I've competed in strongman for about 13
years in that time I started at a key
company tacky is is that he's a
substance using your hands and forearms
to help load Atlas domes
about three or four years ago I started
a gym called spider-strength gym which
is powerfully strongman and
weightlifting and I've also promoted a
few strongman competitions as far as
like an academic background I don't have
much in the way of science
academic background you know my day job
has always been an IT strong man who's
kind of a competitive outlet for me I
got you in just for anyone listening if
you happen to be hearing the sound of my
voice in James's voice and you are I
don't know
within like an hour drive of Raleigh
North Carolina and you're interested in
string sports you should at minimum
check out spider-strength gym or
preferably sign up become a member
hands down one of the best strength gyms
that I had been to it just for some more
background James is the man he runs the
gym that I trained at and it's an
awesome gym so James what uh what got
you into lifting in the first place
I've always liked to lift my lifted in
high school I lift a little bit in
college but usually didn't take like a
friend of mine and I would would go in
we decide okay we're in commit we're
gonna really do this we can get big get
strong and then they show up once and
then never show up again I go like three
or four more times and then kind of quit
again the last time I started I just did
on my own I had trained on my own for
like you know three or four months
I didn't notice quad I didn't know you
know how to lift really I just did what
I could and then one of my co-workers
emailed us some pictures from their
their training I know he did strongman I
didn't know a lot about it he was like a
six foot five 350 pound guy that you
know you see him you expect him to do
strongman at the time I wasn't aware
there were weight classes or anything
like that but you know he sent some
pictures of their workouts and said you
know somewhat sarcastically if you want
to try it to stop by my my house on
Saturdays at noon or whatever and I was
really intrigued so I showed up I you
know didn't know what to expect so and I
showed up you know just wearing jeans
and an excuse to leave you know just cuz
I wasn't sure it was to me a good fit
but the it was a lot of fun they had me
doing sandbag carries and carries from
the start
it was a really educated group most of
the guys there were in graduate programs
and muscular states and I loved it
I've been doing ever since that makes
sense do you have a did you have an
athletic background prior to strong men
or was strong in the first like
organized sport you took part in I did I
competed in football and wrestling in
junior high and through 10th grade
starting 11th grade I started college
early so I played I played rugby for a
year there but besides that I didn't
have much of a letting background I got
to be honest I'm a little bit surprised
usually when we bring in people that are
like high level strength athletes we say
like how did you like or how did you get
into it how did you like it it's always
like well I touch weight once fell in
love never looked back it's really
interesting to hear that you kind of
were in and out a little bit before it
really took hold well a big part of it
for me it's my competitive aspect and
you're just training alone I like to
Train I like getting stronger I like
that progress but it really took the
competitive aspect in the team and the
team aspect as well to to really get me
to just stick around and enjoy it as
much as I do now I mean that that makes
sense I'm very much the same way I I
have tried at various points in my
lifting career to just lift for the fun
of it but I find myself being less and
less consistent if I'm not if I don't
have a meet at least somewhat at least
theoretically on the horizon so I that
definitely resonates with me so so James
what are what are some of your both
biggest lifts and biggest achievements
as a strongman athlete to date so for me
like I've always focused on winning
competitions rather than having big
lifts they do somewhat go hand in hand
but I've always been very disciplined
with training which meant not maxing out
very often
my biggest accomplishment of the
strongman were I want amateur nationals
in 2014 where I earned my pro card that
won the America Strongest Man 105k in
2017 which is like the highest level
show and weight class strongman and then
this year I came back I tried to make
his heavy weight it didn't work out but
this year I came back and got third
place that American are kinda 105k as
far as biggest lifts I I recently hit a
11 1124 pound 18 inch deadlift at the
last competition which I believe is an
18 inch world record against a strongman
isn't really conducive for World Records
because there's so much variability and
equipment and things like that it's
really about compete against people but
it's still a really fun lift cool cool
to have a big number up there I've done
for our pound farmers walks and a lot of
thousand pound yokes and and things like
that but the the deadlift probably
sticks out for me as far as biggest like
lifting achievement yeah I I I saw the
video of it it was absolutely insane and
I mean I I had seen your training videos
leading up to it so I expected to see
something over a thousand but I was
still pretty shocked to see over 1100
that was awesome
I've got a quick question about that so
I assume 18 inches means basically that
the bar position at the start is 18
inches above the ground yep in the
United States 18 inch usually means 18
is to the bottom of the bar so the
blocks are about nine nine and a half
inches tall this particular lifts -
typically in a team's deadlift and
strongman that they would call
silverdollar deadlift and so it'd be a
box you know Trisha Lee Phil of silver
dollars but you know some random stuff
that would be at the end of the bar it's
a small range of motion that this one
was a deadlift bar with calibrated
plates which is good because they want
to set a record so the calibrated plates
kind of made it more more official and
the deadlift bar made it flex a little
bit more like a traditional Silver
Dollar deadlift where the weights
further out and so a typical barbell
deadlift with normal plates would be
Maiki 9 inches from the ground or so
it'd be 9 inches on Center in Evans
bottom okay cool oh man that's a ton of
weight so yeah it's wild
generally it on most people it would
start off just below the knees with a
flex to the bar once you get the slack
out it's it's just above the knees and
you know what's gets both the needs a
lot easier of a list or sure man that
weight is incredible yeah I get a lot
ask a lot of people ask me like what did
it feel like deadlift 1124 pounds and
like I don't know I don't remember you
know you can't your brain doesn't work
just just kind of blackout very much so
so James the vast majority of our
audience the vast majority of the people
who will be listening to this are either
power lifters or bodybuilders or if they
don't compete in powerlifting or
bodybuilding that that's at least kind
of the style of training that they do so
if if one of them or multiple of them
wanted to perhaps try the sport of
strongman after listening to this
interview what what weaknesses would a
typical power lifter and a typical
bodybuilder have just based on you know
kind of standard power lifting or
bodybuilding training if they then
wanted to do a strongman competition
like where what what big like strength
deficits are they going to have relative
to their competitors who do train for
strongman so assuming their trainings
well-rounded so your power lifter but
you still do overhead press usually the
thing that's missing from both would be
a push press there's no equivalent in
powerlifting or bodybuilding
bodybuilders specifically often aren't
the in training they might not lock out
a lot of reps so it's it's kind of a
hard transition for them to lock things
out just because you know they're there
spend more work on time and attention
but the biggest weakness I see from
people of any strengths background it's
not strongman whether it's you know
bodybuilding powerlifting or
weightlifting is kind of a thoracic
extension movement that we haven't
strongman so when you learn a list
you know you first laughs it generally
to get to your lap which is a fairly you
know it's definitely different movement
but its uses muscles you're using anyway
the next part you know you pin the stone
on your chest you know wrap your arms
around it and you stand up with it and
that's a thoracic extension movement
that you don't see any other sports so
it's usually like the thing that takes
longest to develop to be a good
straumann athlete if you're in a
different strength background and you
you see that movement a lot in a lot of
events and strongman in a log clean it's
a similar movement where you're putting
locked to your chest or to your you know
upper belly and then clean it back
that's kind of the same thoracic
movement that you don't see in other
sports so like and I think that's kind
of a weakness that that probably helps
in other areas so it might be worth
doing it for things like back health or
people aren't it really interesting
strongman but you know just want to get
stronger how would someone train that
other than just doing stones and log
cleans it depends on what equipment you
have I would normally just use a sandbag
or keg just because with stones you
generally need to use tacky and things
like that for it not to be like a
separate limiting factor outside of that
extension if you don't have any of those
things that the closest thing at a
normal gym might be zürcher Zeitung of
but it's definitely really nice to have
so I'm kind of like a sandbag thing
where you can work that extension I got
you
all right so building on that last
question somewhat if there are people
listening to this and they you know or
maybe thinking about keeping strongman
to try I think a lot of people are are
hesitant to perhaps you know seek out
and sign up for a strongman show because
they're kind of laboring under the
misconception that all strongmen kind of
look like the archetypal build for
strongmen that you see on
you know world Strongest Man if you've
ever tuned into that on ESPN so you know
you think to be good at the sport you
have to be six foot eight and 400 pounds
so could you just very quickly like
disavow people of that notions like what
what other divisions are there to
compete in and you know just kind of let
people know you don't have to be a
monster of a of a man to make the sport
work so the vast majority of competitors
in the sport compete at a local level
against like regular people in there's
two Federation United States they have
slightly different weight classes but
generally have at least a lightweight
middle eight heavyweight range it's like
hunter 75 pounds uses the lightest class
there's usually a 200 pound weight class
231 weight class then heavy weight
weight class on top of that and for
women it's generally a 140 pounds for
light weight 280 pounds for middle
eights then heavy weight on top of that
and there's also usually novice classes
for people like Newton udas sport or
maybe less let's dedicate to the sport
where the weights are a lot more
manageable for me lifters I got you okay
so you know next thing if someone is
potentially interested in giving
strongman a shot there's a lot of
movements you do a lot of things that
could show up in competition so
generally you would probably want to
find like a crew of strongmen to train
with or a strongman gym so how can you
go about finding strongman gyms if
there's not a strongman gym in your area
how can you go about you know finding
other strongmen to train with and if you
you know if there's not a crew nearby
and there's not a strong man gym nearby
what are some ways that you could you
know make that work either
training solo or training in a
commercial gym so when I started
strongman most people didn't have access
to influence at all you trained in the
gym using regular movements like
everyone else and you showed up the show
and that might be the first time you
touched on it doesn't
it's gotten a lot more competitive since
then so that doesn't work as well as it
used to especially with the availability
of implements generally like you try to
find a crew or a gym there's a website
called starting strongman comm that has
a strong man gym finder and a starting
strongman Facebook group where people
post you know asking hey is there any
groups in this in this area beyond that
if you're you know getting your own
equipment it the you know starting with
a stand bag makes a lot of sense like
rope has their strong wind sandbags
tighten Fitness has a lot of really
cheap charm and stuff that that really
has made a lot more accessible for
people and I mean if you're if you're
the one that's going to take the
initiative and kind of get your own
equipment and start a crew that's I mean
that's awesome we need more of that for
sure
now that website that you mentioned I
think I think it was starting strong man
yep does that also have resources to
help you find competitions in your area
or is it just gyms it does have a
caption finder but it's not very
complete if you're looking for a
strongman competition in your area
there's there's two major United States
Federation strongman corporation and
United States strongmen go to each of
their websites and they both have
upcoming competitions on their site and
so browse that find find the competition
area both federations are great it's
usually the quality the counters depend
on the local promoter more than the
Federation so based on what events you
like you know timing locations things
like that find one that looks fun and
sign up perfect in just a clarification
for the listeners you use the term
implements a few times there if people
aren't aware what that means it's
basically the specialized equipment that
people associate with strongman
competitions is that a reasonable
definition for that yep whether it's
like a log on Atlas stone a sandbag
they're generally just call them
strongman implements yeah and I think a
lot of people as Greg mentioned a lot of
people they're barrier for getting into
strongman is they're in they're like
well I'm not six eight four hundred
pounds I think a lot of them don't
realize
that there are weight you know weight
classes and competitions that account
for that and then the other huge barrier
is while the competition is picking up
giant stones where am I gonna find a
giant stone so you know definitely it's
it's one of those sports where it sounds
like you have to really tap yourself
into a community or at least seek things
out a little bit online yeah it's much
easier if you find a community if you
find a gym you know if a lot of special
people who started it on their own for
sure but the the availability has really
increased the number of competitors in
the sport it's gotten a lot bigger than
it was when I started for sure so James
you know let's assume now someone has
found a crew or they found a strongman
gym to train at and they've registered
for a competition the the next question
I think just based on talking to very
strong men I think any answer you give
will be somewhat contentious because I
know different people have different
philosophies about this but how how
would you personally recommend one go
about balancing kind of general strength
training versus event training because
as I understand it you know you're
you're probably not going to work with
strong strongman implements for 90
percent of your training like there's
probably still going to be just some
standard barbell work in the mix so so
how do you personally think one best
goes about balancing like general
strength training versus event training
like I I personally don't believe that
really general strength exactly a thing
my training revolves around the events
I'm competing in everything I do it's
purposeful to get better at those events
there's other people that just good at
me or better that do strongly believe in
a you know barbell centered training
with with the event training as a side
but I I approach the event training if I
have whether it's like a log press or a
stone over bar or something like that I
would approach those events just like a
power lifter
would approach deadlifts squat and bench
I mean every competition is it's pretty
much like a different strength sports
you have different events and my goal
for that crap is get as good as possible
at those events the best way to do that
is to do do the events and do
accessories that whether they're a
portion of the events portion that lifts
or directly improve that lift that's
what I'm really going to concentrate on
as I get ready for competition but
there's still a lot to be said for you
know general strengths you know a
deadlift at the deadlift some extent
squats will help lots of areas and
strong men as well but I personally
focus on just becoming as good as
possible at these five events and kind
of disregard the concept of general
strength you know just Josiah for the
show just getting stronger at those
events
it proves all of your strengths anyway
so how how often do you compete so like
I know that in general strongmen compete
more often than power lifters or at
least it seems like you guys do but you
know like let's say you register for a
show and it's nine months out like are
you mostly just going to be doing event
training for that show nine months out
for the entire nine months so - or like
what what would like kind of offseason
work look like for you or do you just
kind of not happen offseason so it used
to be that all the shows I did were in
the summer so I'd have a nice long
offseason to build up the weaknesses
they're spread out a lot more the higher
level shows are spread out
you have the artal in February and
Nationals October and Emeric strongest
man in the fall sometime things like
that so it really depends on like what
level show you're doing most shows don't
even announce the events until three or
four months out so it's not like you're
training for it all year I think if
you're training for the same show for
more than four months it probably is too
much you know it's probably hurting your
long-term progress but
you know I would say competitors will
generally want to compete at least three
times per year some some do a lot more
some some are willing to just show up it
shows without really concentrating on
for a long time I'm at the point now
where you know it's I've have a lot of
old injuries and things like that and
I'm happy to compete once or twice a
year but it's I mean we're all doing it
for fun and because we like to compete
so it makes sense to you know do it as
often as you like it's funny to see the
the disparity there we've got our
dietician that stronger by science for
our coaching staff he he competes in
strongman and it seems like every other
week he's at a new competition it's
crazy how much he's competed to last
year and I do bodybuilding and I
basically am on like a presidential
election cycle like every four years
I'll think about it so it's just funny
to see how he gets to engage in that
sport so frequently and get so much
competitive feedback and continue going
to these competitions and I'm like it'd
be cool but I'd probably die so I'll see
you in four years yeah it is all
personal preference I always approach it
as if I sign for a show I'm always going
to dedicate hundred percent to that show
for as long as you know as long as the
events are out there but it's there's a
lot to say for getting strong at
everything and proving it as frequently
as you can all right
so while we're still on the topic of
programming training for strongman the
vast majority of the people listening to
this are primarily going to think of
programming training in terms of sets
and reps you know like five sets of
eight squats or whatever and for for
some exercises or like for some lifts
and strongman that sort of planning
approach would be appropriate but how
how would you kind of program for and
like apply progressive overload and mom
her progress for events that maybe
aren't as amenable to that so for
example things like carries or holds
where you're not you know strictly doing
reps so when strongman there's so
there's a lot more events so a lot of
times you have to spend a good amount of
time just familiarizing yourself with
the event not necessarily like planning
a strength cycle just getting generally
good at that event especially your new
that's really what you're focusing on is
just you know just getting good at it in
general once you kind of past that point
again it's very event specific for yoke
walk is a specific example a heavy oak
walk is a very different movement than a
fast yoke walk when it's if you're going
through a really really heavy yoke
you're generally doing short steps and a
long hold whereas you know letter yoke
your your strides extending and it's
just a very different gait
so for yoke specifically I'm creating
that fast gait lighter than competition
weight in hopes that I can you know get
that same speed you know over my
training cycle over my three months or
whatever I'm working on it
get that same speed I'm doing with the
light yoke to the heavier yoke of the
show by that time and so that means like
a lot of time sets so your your timing
each that you're trying to keep it under
a certain goal time and you know if my
goals eight-second yoke every week I
wanna maybe a heavier eight-second yoke
as I'm approaching you know that that
cop's weight where this you know other
events you might train it very
differently sometimes for a lot of more
complicated medleys you you split up the
different aspects of the medley you
trade it most separately and then where
you get like three weeks out you finally
bring it together
and then get the conditioning aspect of
it in and then like the transitions
aspect of it in so there's it's very
event specific there's no general rules
you can't you you might still like do
some kind of a wave sort of training on
a lot of the mobile events where you're
going heavy every week and then you drop
it back down
just to continue that progress but you
know a lot of us you certainly can't
approach the exactly like you would a
squad or deadlift you you mentioned
medleys what is a typical medley look
like like what would that look like in
competition so a lot of I mean different
shows have very different medleys a lot
of times it might be like a carrion load
where you might have three different
objects that you like pick up carry for
50 feet or 60 feet and load it over a
bar sometimes you might carry and drop
into a sled and drag that sled sometimes
it could be like a wheelbarrow where
you're loading something in the
wheelbarrow then carrying the
wheelbarrow then loading more stuff in
the little barrel it's really just up to
the creativity of the promoter as far as
what could be in the medley which keeps
it interesting you know keeps you know
every every training cycle for a medley
might be a little bit different because
every medal is different and you might
have different opportunities to get
better at it so James as as someone who
you know mostly competes and strongman
but who has at least dabbled in
powerlifting you you're clearly aware
that the the technique requirements and
specifications and just the way that the
two sports approach technique are very
very different insofar as you know
powerlifting basically everything you
can and can't do is strictly defined
whereas some strongman it seems like you
know as long as you move the weight from
point A to point B it's fine so just as
someone who has competed in both of
those sports which approach to technique
do you do you just personally generally
enjoy more and what what pros and cons
do you see to you know kind of like the
the laissez-faire approach to like
technical specifications in competition
for the lifts being performed
so I appreciate the the powerful aspect
of it where you keep everything very
defined
no one's gonna come up with any new
tricks to squat more or anything like
that it's a lot more pure as far as you
know getting stronger it's a lot easier
to study in science because it's very
well-defined there's no there's no new
secrets no no new techniques are gonna
come out strong man has so many events
that you still see new ways to do things
that hadn't been done before a couple
years ago you know cake pressing is a
pretty common event in strongman and
typically you would clean the keg like
you would a log or lifting a stone and
then press it from there
recently someone discovered if you clean
the log vertically so it's you know
vertical on your on your lap and then
pop your hips to push the the lower end
up it's a more effective lift for for a
lot of people so like you know I've been
doing strongman for like 10 years at
this point I've never even thought of
that so it's pretty cool that there's
still new ways to find to do these lifts
that haven't been done before you know I
personally appreciate the strongman
aspect of your you're gonna find the
optimum way to lift it for you without
any restrictions as far as movements go
as an example and on deadlifting
strongman allows hitching and ramping
where power often does not
I don't believe a deadlift is a natural
movement because you have to keep your
knees behind the bar you know so you're
you're not in your optimal different
position because your knees have to stay
back in strongmen for me if I'm much
stronger if my knees come forward when
when the bar gets past my legs so I'm
going to ramp every rep even if I don't
have to just because it's it's easier
it's it's more efficient my body type
can lift more that way so I'm gonna make
it easier because I can so I mean I
appreciate the the ability to lift it in
the way that's best for you rather than
having like a tight set of rules that's
a really fascinating perspective I've
never thought of it that way but the
idea that you're in a sport where you
can still make like meaningful
qualitative changes to the way events
are performed that would be a really
exciting thing
yeah it's it's the the what's called the
Fox brewery flop in in high jump like
just there's still opportunities in
strongman to to do things a different
way that that hasn't been done before
and it's it's cool to see it's like Greg
you were telling me a story a while back
about that guy who showed up to the race
like a super long-distance race oh yeah
cliff Young I think yeah yeah he showed
up and just like yeah I've run a little
bit differently than everybody and just
like absolutely killed everyone right
well so for him it was two things so one
like everyone thought his running
technique was ridiculous because it was
he was more of like a shuffle than a
running stride so like head down and
legs mostly stiff not been in your knees
a bunch but the the biggest thing that
gave him an advantage is that he could
run for five days straight without
sleeping all of his competition that had
never occurred to them that like oh I
can run 600 miles and never sleep but
yeah so the thing with his running
technique is it turns out that it was
actually quite biomechanically efficient
and for the race being run which I think
was Sydney to Melbourne
I don't know Australian geography that
well it was two cities that were like
approximately six seven hundred miles
apart anyway just racing between those
two cities and it turns out if you run
for six seven hundred miles straight you
generate a ton of eccentric stress if so
doing kind of like a stiffer leg shuffle
to where you're not accumulating as much
ease centric stress on your quads turns
out to not be a bad way to run seven
hundred miles but you know when the race
started everyone was like who is this
guy and why does his technique suck so
hard
and then after he completely demolished
everyone they studied his running
technique and they're like oh no
actually pretty good so James we've
talked a lot about
training but obviously there's there's a
you know any kind of strength sport
there's going to be some influence of
nutrition in the way you're eating
within the sport of strongman is there
currently a big focus on nutrition among
some of the higher level competitors I
would say yes I think you know
culturally early on there's a lot of you
know just eat lots and you know just
lots calories lots of everything I think
now more and more getting into you know
tighter diets the vertical diets gotten
popular among a lot of top athletes it's
it was a aspect that was kind of not
addressed well enough for a lot of
competitors for a long time and I think
now they're they're cleaning up their
diets and I think the performance are
going out because of it so for me
personally I kind of for a lot of
straumann so I kind of look more at like
nutrition that maybe football players
would use over a powerlifter just
because of the athletic part of it with
a big focus on intra workout carbs the
you know seems to make a big difference
for me at least yeah and so you
mentioned the vertical diet by name is
is that kind of the the singular
predominant dietary strategy that's kind
of trending currently or other are there
like competing dietary paradigms
currently at the highest level the
vertical guys real popular a
nutritionist named Nathan Payton has
done the diets for he's doing the diet
from our teams and he's doing Brian Shaw
and he's been real popular he does a lot
of a lot of his work is around insulin
insulin sensitivity and things like that
I think most people don't follow like a
named diet they just use good general
principles but there's there's
definitely a bigger focus on diet than
they used to be so James this this next
question I think will probably be the
most I don't know possibly controversial
in the episode it shouldn't be but
people are ridiculous
and it is about drugs in strongman so as
I understand it
at this point like virtually virtually
no or or literally no strongman shows
are drug tested but obviously there are
still a lot of drug-free people who
compete and strongman you know probably
just not World's Strongest Man in that
level so like just in general if
someone's listening to this like let's
say they're a drug-free power lifter and
they want to give strongman a shot
how how out of place are they going to
feel as a drug-free athlete and and to
what degree can they still be
competitive in the sport you know
assuming they have somewhat decent
strength genetics if they don't decide
to take the plunge so a lot of people
think everyone's using and a lot of
people think not many people are using
and I'm sure they're both pretty wrong I
would say I believe in strongman drugs
help less than it would in powerlifting
because there's more aspects that are
just static strength at a local show I
would say the use of drugs barely makes
any impact the drug-free lifters went
just as much that the ones that are
using drugs just because the local level
you know the skill and experience and
athleticism plays a much bigger part at
like the world Strongest Man level and
Arnold level all those guys were using
the the last real high-level top
heavyweight that I know of would have
been probably feel faster when he won
and I think 2006 but I mean it's it's a
not untested sport drugs are always
going to help heavyweights the most
because they don't have a weight cap so
yeah you see a lot in in the the high
highest level heavyweights there are a
lot of heavy way strong and they're very
good and drug-free a lot of the top 10
guys from the Arnold amateur strongman
heavyweight remind show were drug-free
it's and it helps the lower weight class
that helps less so you're gonna see a
lot
more drug-free assets the 175s and 200
and un two heavyweights as well it it's
tough to I mean most people aren't that
public about it but there's there's kind
of been a shift I believe over the last
few years where people are being more
more public about it and all the likes
of Instagram mean pages make drug memes
all the time so I I do believe people
are starting to think that everyone's
using more than ever and people who
don't use are starting to feel more out
of place so I think that's kind of
becoming a problem people underestimate
how good you can get without drugs and
then it honestly I believe when you
start believing everyone's using
everyone speeding you is using that
creates a big nocebo effect where you
know if you think you're losing because
you're not taking drugs you're gonna
start losing you know because you think
that it so it's definitely tough
position it's it's and it's tough with
strongman because drug testing doesn't
fit in the strongman model very well in
peril of doing performances are based on
Wilkes so you don't need a lot of people
in your class have a competition and
strongman it's it's you're not competing
against the weights as much you're
competing against people all your score
is based on how you do compared to the
other people in your class so you need a
decent size class to have real
competition
if you drug test at a local level you
might be eliminating eliminating like a
fairly large percentage of the potential
competitors which might mean a smaller
show which you know just makes it harder
to have a show so you know I don't think
drug testing makes sense to local level
between that and the fact I don't
believe it helps that much I would like
to see higher level off to new
opportunities for drug-free athletes
just so that you know that they don't
feel like they're they can't go very far
if they don't start using just because I
mean a lot of people are starting to
feel disenfranchised by the amount of of
people publicly talked about their drug
use and the the idea that everyone's
using so I know one of the things that
you've told me before is that your kind
of kicking around the idea of maybe
trying to have a drug tested Nationals
within you know the next few years or
something
how is that plan coming along and how if
if it worked out how do you think that
would maybe change the face of strongman
at least in America in you know possibly
encourage more people to give the sport
a shot so I guess some background Strama
incorporation is is you know of course
one of the two federations Arnold
Schwarzenegger is in the process of
buying a stake instrument corporation so
he's going to be very influential as far
as the direction of the organization
goes and as he's been very health
focused recently I know he's been very
concerned about the health of some of
the top level athletes so I think he
would be open to having a separate drug
test Nationals but you know again only
time will tell that I I think you know
that I can't imagine it changing the the
top level the world trunks man things
because people want to see the biggest
in the strongest but on the amateur
level the local level you're not selling
tickets your customer is the athletes
themselves and it having this another
opportunity for athletes that are drug
free to compete at a high level against
other drug free athletes I think would
be great for the consumers
so like hopefully we can make it happen
at some point
I think it'd keep a lot more people in
the sport it probably bring some new
sponsors on board that are kind of
afraid to sponsor these competitions
because of the association with drugs
and I mean I would love to see that
happen yeah that that would be really
really cool I think like so - talking to
some of my buddies who are peril if ters
one one I guess like dirty little secret
in powerlifting is a lot of power
lifters think or I would say recognize
that strongman is objectively a cooler
sport
but I think a lot of especially like us
APO guys and drug-free powerlifters are
are a little bit hesitant to give
strongly in a shot because there is you
know there is that perception well one
the fact that none of it is drug tested
and then kind of building on that the
perception that oh if you're competing
in an untested sport like you must be
using as well so I think like having at
least some avenue of of drug tested
competition at least somewhere in the
hierarchy of the sport would help lessen
that perception to some degree and and
probably get a lot more people to sign
up and do their first show so I think
that would be really really cool yeah I
actually I actually had a weightlifter
who was trekking strongman training with
us for strongman and he told me he took
me aside and said you know what I wanted
out of here myself 100% to strongman I'm
ready to go what do I need to take and
like it was really disappointing because
he's brand new he had two years of huge
gains without drugs at least and like
the expectation was you need to start to
do well and that's just not the case and
just I mean having having a darkness
national I think that would help
alleviate that that mindset no yeah for
sure and I mean like I think like people
compete people compete in strength
sports for different reasons and I I
think like strongman is probably
different from powerlifting in that
regard because like like you mentioned
earlier in this interview you know power
lifting the weights weigh what they
weigh their Wilk scores whatever like
you can show up to compete against your
competitors but the vast majority of
people are just showing up to compete
against their prior PRS because
ultimately whether you win or lose like
a local powerlifting meet or not it just
kind of depends who shows up if like
just kind of the local crop shows up
maybe you win or if
like a national or world-class level
lifter you know needs to the qualifying
total for Nationals and shows up you
know you go from winning to being a
distant distant second just solely based
on who showed up for the show
whereas in strongman it is much more
like head-to-head competition and you
know competing against your class rather
than competing against like your old PRS
so I think that like I think that people
who are kind of more competitively
minded would would probably you know
very much enjoy being able to compete in
a manner where they know that they know
that their competitors aren't able to do
something that they personally don't
feel comfortable with for whatever
reason cuz I mean you know it's one
thing to know that you're going into
some sort of competition with a handicap
and still winning like that feels
awesome but you know if you
realistically wind up losing more than
you win and you know that like you know
there's a decent chance that I would do
better if I broke some walls you know
that that's just not a great position
for people to be in yeah it definitely
isn't so on the the topic of you know
just competing in general one one key
difference between powerlifting and
strongman is in powerlifting
you know there's little holes in the
weights you can go up and down you can
make sure that the weights are light
enough that you can get your opener in
that is not always the case in strongman
if you're not strong enough you can zero
events and you know just completely wash
out of the competition so how if someone
is you know kind of decently strong
already but not exceptionally strong
what are some ways that they can know
that kind of you
we'll be worthwhile for them to show up
to a strongman show and they're not just
gonna like zero everything and have a
bad time so one of the things a lot of
look motors are doing to help alleviate
that is to have what we call Trump
weights where you you have a main weight
so it might be like let's say it's a
hundred eighty pound log press four reps
to zero the two eighty you might bill go
down to a 240 and you know still get
some points you know you lose everyone
that gets anywhere up to 280 but it
would just make a lot more accessible
they did something similar at the Arnold
was like the the heavy log you know a
couple people get the heavy log in or
else could've done later log that makes
a lot more accessible but as far as like
if you know I would say generally
there's a lot more people who feel that
they're not ready to compete in
strongman chill but already then people
who feel they're ready but aren't ready
you know I think it's okay to zero an
event or two if anything that that it's
nice to get a starting point you know
you might get you know last place that's
a starting point you can do a little bit
better every single competition and you
have that experience you know you know
what you need to work on I mean it's
okay to zero something as you know it's
it's again it's all about having fun
it's you don't have to win every show I
gotcha
so just shifting gears slightly you
mentioned that for yourself you have a
somewhat extensive injury history and
when when you look into the research on
injury rates and strength sports it
doesn't seem like the injury rate for
strongman is like catastrophic Lehigh or
anything like that like it's certainly
still considerably lower than say
American football but but the research
that does exist seems to suggest that
the injury rate for strongman might be
somewhere in the neighborhood of about
twice as high as it is for powerlifting
and weightlifting so first off does that
match kind of your experience you know
competing in strongman and then also
running in just a general strength
sports gym
- what sorts of injuries are the most
common in strongman and then three what
uh you know what prehab work what
modifications what sort of precautions
can people take if they want to compete
in strongman - you know not completely
get rid of any injury risk but at least
at least mitigate those risks to some
degree I think it does make sense that
there's a lot more injuries in strongman
and in powerlifting simply there's
there's a few reasons there's a lot more
variety of events and some events are
inherently more dangerous tons of of
injuries on tire flip for example then
trauma has the additional risk of you
know with all the odd objects and things
like that I've seen a few people you
know dropping out list on themselves you
know that's not gonna happen a power of
things so you get a whole nother avenue
to get potentially injuries in strongman
and powerlifting has a lot of pretty
well defined training programs that you
know you kind of know it's going to
happen
we're in strongman that that doesn't
exist and if you program wrong you're
you might be overusing something you're
under using something and it's you know
just not a program you can recover from
well and that increase the intro risk as
well so it doesn't make sense is more
interesting strongman
the only mitigating thing is I think
there might be some fewer kind of
repetitive stress sort of injuries
because there are a lot more stuff we
work on a lot more variety and that that
kind of helps with there seems to be
some pretty good longevity of a lot of
high level strongman surgery Savickas
was top two in the world for fifteen
years which I mean you might see some of
that powerful thing but it seems like
you see more of the really long run
jeopardy and strongman than you do in in
similar strength sports so it it's the
it certainly makes sense there's more
injuries that's part of the sport as far
as prehab rehab goes the bicep tears are
probably the most common injury and
strongmen and that's
you know you do a lot of eccentric work
to built that tenant up but then when I
go so far people who are very religious
about their prehab still will tear
biceps occasionally so you just you
mitigate the risk of the best you can
list in your body most of my injuries
like after they happened I look back and
like hey I had some clues I ignored you
know so that I mean if you're paying
attention to that it can certainly help
but you know it injuries happen and to
me it's it's just part of you know doing
the sport it's not it's not that big of
a deal it just means I can't move this
arm for this many months and then I'm
back to normal you know oh man
I love how you phrase that because I
think that's how I would approach it as
well but kind of to the average person
oh just can't move this arm for a few
months would seem like a big deal but I
mean yes sometimes that's that's just
the price of admission for a sport yeah
and I mean but bicep surgery has gotten
really good lately you know I tore my
bicep a couple years ago and you know
they they do a nerve block so there's no
pain one that you know after the surgery
until that night and there's a
well-defined recovery period after it's
all healed up a stronger than ever
as far as injuries that I've had the
bicep tear was probably one of like
affected my strength career less than a
lot of like 10 a nice issues it affected
me less than my patellar tendonitis and
golfer's elbow and and a lot of other
things so he's kept it in perspective I
must say I feel like a like a complete
tendon rupture would be a pretty
distressing thing to go through but in
terms of the aftermath like man I'll
take anything that's not a back injury
like because you know like like you said
with with a limb injury it's like okay
well I'm gonna hobble around I'll be on
crutches I won't use that arm whatever
that's fine but like there's nothing
worse than when you're like I hope I
don't sneeze in the next three weeks
because I am NOT physically prepared to
sneeze and if I do it's gonna be
horrible yeah my specific bicep injury
like
it it worked out really well because it
happened at America's strongest man in
2017 it was on the fourth event it was
an arm over arm like a rope pull happen
last pull I still got second on that
event the fifth event was a deadlift and
we can use straps in strongman so I was
in first going into the last event I was
syllable deadlift with my completely
detached bicep I got second in that
event and it tied me for first overall
so it's a tiebreaker
they you know it's trauma is a show
first above everything else they wanted
a good tie breaker show for the audience
and that meant well it couldn't be
anything that I couldn't do you know so
they did a one-handed farmer's hold and
I you know one the one I had a farmer
sold was my you know one attached bicep
and it was a really cool moment and I
was ready to take a break anyway like I
was as ready to lay off you know I've
been training and treating so hard that
I tried to take some time off anyway so
the timing was great
the surgery was easy I mean I couldn't
ask for a better bicep tear I'm gonna be
honest man the idea of deadlifting with
a detached bicep really grosses me out
that seems so gross to me but with that
that's a really cool story man yeah well
it couldn't get any more detached yeah
and I know it works I it was a 675 axial
deadlift and I think I got four wraps I
had more in me but I couldn't hold him
the bar anymore like my straps are
slipping so but I mean it's such a good
story
I would be most concerned that I
dislocate a shoulder at that point
because your your biceps are one of the
primary restraints against dislocating a
shoulder if there's like downward
traction like that good thing that
didn't happen it's not like if me that
arm for a while anyway though you know
fair enough
that that's a great point if there was a
time to dislocate a shoulder you know
when you're already going to have bicep
surgery couldn't pick a better time for
a dislocation
yeah so I am getting towards the end of
the questions I had prepared but just
for for the people listening at home I
think a lot of the top super-heavyweight
male strong men in the world are pretty
well known at this point so you have
Thor yet Bryan Shaw you have Eddie Hall
those are kind of household names at
this point kind of within the general
strength training community especially
the strength sports community but who
else kind of should be on our radar and
kind of specifically here you know most
people listening to this may really
enjoy watching you know giants like Thor
and Brian Shaw lift super heavy stuff
you know your 510 200 pounds and it's
it's impressive but not entirely
relatable so what what are some you know
either super heavyweights on the come-up
but then just also like awesome
strongmen in strongmen and strong women
in other weight classes that people
should know about and maybe be able to
look to for inspiration from people who
possibly look more like them for the
heavy way it's the the top contender
right now is matthias killed a Kowski i
think he recently won some shows he's
he's probably gonna beat Martines at
world Strongest Man this year I think
Thor and char kind of on the way down a
big contender is a Alexey Novikov he's
he competed he competes a lot he
competed like ten times in two months
recently but if he can take some time
off and dedicate himself he's really
athletic doesn't have the frame as the
big guys but he's gonna be a contender
I think this coming up here at world
Strongest Man as far as other classes
there's coming up this weekend is the
official strongman games it's like the
World's Strongest Man for horse walks
woman for the weight classes and world
sharks man for for the weight classes
it'll have been a week or two ago when
this air
but there's a lot of exciting classes
there the lightweight women has Rhiannon
Lovelace she won the world sharks
man-wolf next woman under 140 last year
she's got near 600 pound deadlift I'm
just amazingly ecstatically strong
there's nothin comer named Ilyas alcone
that's American that's that's had a very
impressive year that the good you know
battle for that title there's a lot of
middle eight women that are the
establishment of wait women are Lefou
Ingles and Kim Dirk's they've been the
top two for the couple years there's a
new contender Dani
baaji who just did a 285 lock press she
could become like the new top 180 in
women's class pretty soon we what oh
yeah then a 180 pound woman with a 285
log press yes holy [ __ ] that's
ridiculous
you you you can keep going I'm just
gonna like a chuckle to myself for a
second I hope I write with the weight
right yeah I'm pretty sure that was it
yeah so she she's uh may may now be the
top 180 women will need to find a
competition where all three of them beat
again she she I think she's still under
180 she might she might weigh a little
more now but uh she's she's been I just
looked up her current body weighs 202
but she's been convenient under 180 for
the most part there's a lot of great
heavyweight women coming up it's you
know for years it was Kristin Rhodes and
Donna more we're like the top two by far
and now like Andrea Thompson's up there
and and Jessica Fidan and hailey Randall
and a few others are knocking on that
door as far as you know top women in the
heavyweights so I mean it's exciting
this kind of the the numbers are going
up faster than ever in my opinion
especially in the ones classes cool in
full
or the for the lighter men's classes in
the middle weights for Americans just
last week in America trucks man there's
a newer competitor named Jesse Nelson
he's he's strict lock press 3 at 390 in
training he went for a world record and
just missed it
a dimeric structure analog press he's
got a ton of potential he won the log
press America trucks man and he he won
the yoke but what's noteworthy like he's
fairly new so he still has a lot of
potential there
his technique doesn't look very good you
just pure strength so that means there's
to me there's a lot of opportunity for
me to get better so I could see him
being the top 105k very soon another top
105k to watch Chad Korean he was
traditionally a heavyweight he you know
made to the main stage the Arnold
amateur is a heavyweight in the past
years last year was his first year
competing at 231 he had a rotator cuff
tear I think or some shoulder injury
that kind of held him back but healthy
he might be like one of the new top 105
K's so like right now the top Americans
are territory ready
Anthony Fuhrman and I and we're you know
Anthony I are pretty injured Terry might
be I don't know what his plans are but I
know he had some some heart issues so he
might be on the way down so it's
exciting to watch some of the new guys
you know kind of take the plate take our
place and you know become the new top
Americans in 105k sounds good so so that
is the end of my pre-prepared questions
obviously you know way more about the
sport of strongman than I do
so is uh is there anything else you'd
like to share about the sport in general
advice or information for people who are
interested in giving strongman a shot or
just basically anything that I know too
little to think to ask you about just
you know just here in closing just to
make sure that you know anything that
someone could possibly want to get out
of this interview if they want to give
straw
in a shot they do get out of it and keep
in mind this is basically the the final
opportunity to really put a nice
highlight reel together for your
audition so you know use this
opportunity to its maximum potential so
I think so a lot of strong men could be
empowering also not a lot of peril
towards competing strong men also and it
does make sense a lot more stuff to
learn but I think people need to should
know that you don't have to you know be
great at to compete it's a fun sport it
might be a side thing it could help
build some strengths the bill ups
weaknesses he didn't know you had so I
would encourage people that do
powerlifting you know spend a couple
months try outs and strongman and you
know just just give it a shot it's it's
a lot of fun it's a great culture I mean
the culture is pretty similar
powerlifting it's really supportive and
you know it's it's just a nice different
strength sport that that's definitely
worth giving a shot alright well that
that does it for us where where can
people find you if they want to follow
you and your stuff and is there anything
you would like to show for your in
closing anything I'd like to show for ya
you know stuff to promote engage in
capitalism so to speak yeah so the gyms
pretty busy already so I'm not I don't I
don't like advertise show you more
members but if you if you're in Raleigh
and you want to go to a real solid
strength gym check out spider strike gym
I'm commuting on Instagram I'm Jay def
Pro strongman on Instagram and yeah
reach out follow me see what strong
men's about sweet alright well that that
does it for us thank you so much for
taking the time out of your day to come
out dreams yeah thanks for having me
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]